This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《学得艰难》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。这向全世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，收听《学得艰难》。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是数字2%。当一群女性发现她们都跟同一个惯犯骗子约会过后，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. And welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everyone. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast if you're joining us for the first time. What an episode to choose. and I think it's going to be particularly fun,
在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信我，宝贝》（Trust Me, Babe）。欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客里，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。如果你是第一次加入我们，欢迎来到这个播客。选了这么一期节目。而且我觉得它会特别有趣，
but full of some good insights, maybe, possibly, let me know after you're done listening. Yeah, this is more of a chatty episode. When I do, like, structured episodes, they take so long. They take, like, four hours, five hours to, like, research and record. And sometimes there's moments like this where I just have this thought, I have something I want to talk about. And I just think it feels more.
但也可能充满了很好的见解，也许吧，听完之后告诉我吧。是的，这是一期比较像闲聊的节目。每当我做那种结构化的节目时，它们都要花好长时间。研究和录制需要花四五个小时。有时会有这样的时刻，我只是突然有了这个想法，我有想聊的话题。我只是觉得这样更……
more authentic to just discuss, just to share what I think about it, instead of going into, you know, journal articles and peer-reviewed studies. And this just happened to be one of those moments. We're going to talk about loneliness today. We're going to talk about what it feels like to be lonely. Why we feel lonely. Yeah, kind of darker. I don't know. I still think it's just such an important thing to talk about. I don't know what's going around in the world at the moment, but so many people, so many of my friends that I'm talking to are really feeling this way, have been having this feeling for a while. And I've been trying to put my finger on it because I'm in the same boat. And the thing that I've come to the conclusion is that in your 20s
直接分享我对它的看法，而不是去查阅那些学术期刊和同行评审的研究，这样显得更真实、更自然。而这恰好就是那种时刻之一。我们今天要聊聊孤独。我们要聊聊感到孤独是什么感觉。为什么我们会感到孤独。是的，这话题有点深沉。我不知道。我依然觉得这是个非常重要的话题。我不知道现在世界上都在发生什么，但是有那么多的人，我聊天的那么多朋友，真的都有这种感觉，这种感觉已经持续了一段时间。我一直在试图弄清楚原因，因为我也身处其中。我得出的结论是，在二十多岁时，
especially, everything is so transformative. Everything is changing. and the life that you had a couple of years ago, even six months ago, is not the same life that you have now. And as my friends are getting into their mid and late 20s, there's been some pretty major life adjustments, both positive and not so much negative, but hard ones, difficult life changes. And I think that creates this sense of loneliness that so many people and so many of my friends and I have been discussing recently, you know, moving, moving into new jobs, changing your life structure, gone to the days when we were all in uni or all just out of high school or in our first jobs or trades, and had a lot of free time
尤其是这个时期，一切都是如此具有变革性。一切都在改变。几年前、甚至六个月前你过的生活，已经和现在的不同了。随着我的朋友们进入二十岁的中后期，生活发生了一些相当重大的调整，既有积极的调整，也有说不上消极、但却是艰难的调整，也就是困难的生活转变。我认为这造成了一种孤独感，我和身边的很多人、很多朋友最近一直在讨论这种感觉，你知道的，搬家，换新工作，改变生活结构。我们都在上大学、刚高中毕业、或者刚开始第一份工作或手艺的那种日子已经一去不复返了，那时候我们有大量的空闲时间，
and had a lot of time to see each other, to form new connections. We just had so many more opportunities to meet people and to feel seen and to feel understood. And we just don't have that anymore. A lot of my friends are getting their first full-time jobs. That's like eight, hours out of every day that now you spend with co-workers instead of, you know, your friends,
有大量的时间去看望彼此，建立新的联系。我们有更多太多的机会去结识新朋友，去被看见、被理解。而我们现在已经没有这些了。我的很多朋友都找到了第一份全职工作。这意味着每天有八个小时的时间，你现在是和同事度过，而不是和你的朋友们，
instead of people that, whose company you really enjoy, maybe you love your co-workers. But I would say for the most part, it's a job. It's different to the people you'd choose. And the other thing I've noticed is a lot of my friends have gotten partners. And there's kind of two reasons this creates, like not a loneliness, but like a dynamic of like disconnect sometimes. you spend so much more time with your partner, that being one thing. And I guess if you don't do it right, you can end up feeling like you've lost people, feeling like you're missing out on fun things. And then for your friends, so like such as myself, a lot of my friends have gotten partners
而不是和那些你真正喜欢和他们在一起的人度过，也许你很爱你的同事。但我想大多数情况下，这只是一份工作。它和你自己选择的人是不一样的。我注意到的另一件事是，我的很多朋友都有了伴侣。这在某种程度上造成了两个原因，不是孤独，而是一种有时会产生脱节感的动态关系。你花更多的时间和你的伴侣在一起，这是一方面。我想如果你没有处理好，你最后可能会觉得你失去了其他人，觉得你错过了好玩的事情。然后对于你的朋友们，比如像我这样的人，我的很多朋友都有了伴侣，
recently or in the last year. And of course their life is going to be more centered around the people they're going to grow with, you know, romantically and intimately and build their lives with. and it can feel like you're quite on the out if you haven't found that person yet. And that's something I really want to discuss today because I've just been thinking about it a lot and thinking about what it means to outgrow people, what it means to feel lonely after you've lost people. And does that really mean it's a bad thing? That's something that's been on my mind as I've moved, as I've grown.
最近或在过去的一年里。当然，他们的生活将更多地围绕着那些与他们在浪漫和亲密关系中共同成长、共建生活的人展开。如果你还没有找到那个人，你可能会觉得自己相当被冷落。这正是我今天真的很想讨论的事情，因为我一直在思考这个问题，思考超越旧圈子意味着什么，思考在失去朋友后感到孤独意味着什么。这真的意味着这是一件坏事吗？这是我随着搬家、随着成长一直在脑海中思考的问题。
A lot of people I'm just not in touch with anymore. and it means that the quantity of friends I have has reduced, but has the quality really reduced as a result as well. That's something we're going to tackle also. And the media, movies, films, how are they contributing to this kind of dialogue that to feel lonely is to be a failure, is to be alone when that's not really the case.
我和很多人已经不再联系了。这意味着我拥有的朋友数量减少了，但因此质量真的也下降了吗？这也是我们将要探讨的问题。还有媒体、电影、影片，它们是如何助长这种对话的：感到孤独就是一种失败，孤身一人就是失败，而事实并非如此。
Yeah, just a lot of things, a less structured episode today, if that's what you like, well then you've chosen a great time to listen in. If not, we will be back with the highly researched episodes next week. But let's get into it. Let's get into my thoughts on the topic of loneliness. So I've been feeling lonely recently.
是的，就是很多事情，今天是一期结构比较松散的节目，如果你喜欢这种风格，那么你今天算是来对了。如果没有，我们下周还会推出经过深入研究的节目。但让我们切入正题吧。让我们进入我对孤独这个话题的想法。我最近也感到孤独。
Maybe you kind of got that from the first part of this episode. But I've been feeling really lonely. And I've been trying to kind of come to terms with that. And in some ways fix it. but also like appreciate the emotion for what it is. Loneliness these days, I think we have a tendency to really fear it, but we also feel it a lot deeper and a lot stronger. And it's more kind of in our faces when we do feel like we're not surrounded by good people
也许你从这集的前半部分听出来了。但我确实感到非常孤独。我一直在试图接受这一点。在某些方面去解决它。但同时也去欣赏这种情绪本身的意义。现在的孤独，我认为我们往往真的很害怕它，但我们也感受得更深、更强烈。当我们觉得身边没有好人时，这种感觉就更直接地扑面而来，
or not supported or don't have community because of social media, seeing everyone else with their amazing bands of friends and doing incredible things. It makes the feeling you have within yourself a bit more bitter. It stinks, I think, a little bit more. And I just don't think that's the right attitude to have. So for me, I've moved cities recently. It's meant that I've left a lot of my old friends behind. And it really sucks.
或者没有得到支持，或者因为社交媒体而缺乏社群感，看到每个人都在和他们神奇的朋友团一起做不可思议的事情。这会让内心的这种感觉变得更加苦涩。我觉得这有点让人难受。我不认为这是应该有的态度。对我来说，我最近搬了城市。这意味着我把许多老朋友留在了身后。这真的很糟糕。
It really sucks because I'm an extrovert, I think, just in nature. And not having those people to talk to all the time, to fill my days with, to do fun things with is really difficult. And it leaves you feeling like you're a lot of. when that's possibly and most likely not the case. Loneliness hurts us so much because the absence of social connection, it kind of triggers, it doesn't kind of, it triggers the same primal alarm bells as, you know, hunger, thirst, physical pain.
这真的很糟糕，因为我觉得自己天生是个外向的人。没有那些人可以一直聊天、填满我的日子、一起做有趣的事情，这真的很困难。这会让你觉得自己有很多……而这可能、而且极有可能是错误的情况。孤独之所以让我们如此痛苦，是因为缺乏社交连接会引发——不是“有点”，而是会引发与饥饿、口渴、身体疼痛相同的原始警报。
Being surrounded by people, having a community, having social connections is as vital to our well-being as, you know, having a safe place to live, having food to eat, having a sense of security. We really can't understate how important it is to feel surrounded by those who you could lean upon or just people who you have fun with. So this is what I think happens a lot in our 20 years. You kind of do uni or you do your first job in a certain environment. And normally it's quite close-knit and then you move.
被人群包围、拥有一个社群、建立社交连接，对我们的幸福感至关重要，就像拥有一个安全的生活场所、有饭吃、有安全感一样。我们真的不能低估被那些你可以依靠的人、或者仅仅是和你一起玩得很开心的人包围是多么重要。所以这就是我认为在我们二十多岁时经常发生的事情。你读完大学，或者在某个特定的环境中找到第一份工作。通常这个圈子非常紧密，然后你搬家了。
People move, people change, people quit jobs, people get partners, people make new friends. And sometimes there's a gap between when you move on and others move on or when you kind of make that leap before everyone else has. Or alongside other people who you don't know about yet. And that's kind of the thing I've been experiencing. I talk to my friend Sydney about this all the time. If you're listening, Sydney, love you to bits. But she had this experience. And I hope she doesn't mind me talking about it because it is quite comforting to think about how much she's kind of
人们搬家，人们改变，人们辞职，人们找到伴侣，人们结交新朋友。有时，当你向前迈进、其他人向前迈进之间，或者当你比其他人更早迈出这一步时，会存在一个真空期。或者与那些你还不了解的人并肩同行。这就是我一直在经历的事情。我经常和我的朋友悉尼（Sydney）谈论这件事。如果你在听的话，悉尼，超级爱你。但她有过这段经历。我希望她不介意我谈论这件事，因为当我在这种情绪中时，回想她从这个过程中成长和学到了多少，其实是相当宽慰的。但她去年搬到了墨尔本。她搬离了堪培拉，那是我认识她的地方，她的整个社群都在这里建立起来了。她在这里有个伴侣。她在这里有朋友。她在这里有工作和家人。她是在封锁期间搬家的。一个糟糕的时机。绝对是搬到一个新城市的糟糕时机。这意味着她得呆在室内，意味着她没有机会结识新朋友。正当这一切发生时，她原本所在的堪培拉并没有封锁。大家依然在出门。大家都在做有趣的事情。
have grown and learnt from the process when I'm kind of in my feels about it. But she moved to Melbourne last year. She moved away from Canberra, which was where I met her, and her whole community was established here. She'd had a partner here. She had friends here. She had work and family here. And she moved during lockdown. Terrible time. Absolutely terrible time to move to a new city. And it meant that she was inside, meant that she didn't have the opportunity to meet new people. And as that was happening, Canberra, where she was originally from, wasn't in lockdown. Everyone was still going out. Everyone was doing fun things.
我想我可以安全地假设，或者说，她感到孤独。我们经常讨论这个话题，因为当我今年搬到悉尼时，我给她打了电话，我说，我发现交朋友真的很难。要遇到能产生共鸣的人真的很难。她说，你必须要——她几乎给了我一个医嘱。她说，你必须要对一切都说“YES”。走出去，独自做事情。做你自己。
And I think I would be safe to assume that I would, to say that, you know, she felt lonely. And we talked about this a lot because when I made the move to Sydney this year, I, like, called her about it. And I was like, I just find, it's really hard to make friends. It's really hard to meet people that you feel a kinship with. And she was like, you just have to, she almost gave me, like, almost like a doctor's orders. She was like, you've just got to say yes to everything. Go out and do things alone. Just be your own self.
如果你想去参加一个活动，就自己去。你会遇到人的。我想，好吧，首先，这非常有勇气，也非常勇敢。我不知道我能不能做到。但我做到了。我一直在努力这样做。她完全是对的。但这就像，事情并不总是那么简单。
If you want to go to an event, go by yourself. You'll meet people. And I was like, well, first off, that is incredibly courageous and very brave. I don't know if I can do that. But I did it. I've been really trying to do that. And she's absolutely right. But that's like, it's not always as simple as that.
而且我认为这也需要时间。在你真正开始向外展示自己，到你真正建立起新的友谊和新的连接之间的这段时间，是非常孤立的。我认为人们很容易陷入这样一种思维定式：认为有一个公式可以解决孤独。这有两个问题。首先，孤独就像我们感受到的任何其他情绪一样。心理学上有一句名言：如果它没有价值，如果它没有目的，它就不会存在。我认为孤独非常符合这个描述。
And it takes time, I think, as well. And that time in between when you really start putting yourself out there, and when you do make those new friendships and those new connections is really isolating. I think that it's very easy to get into this mindset of like there is an equation to fix loneliness. There's two issues with that. Firstly, loneliness is like any other emotion that we feel. There is this saying in psychology that if it didn't serve a value, if it didn't have a purpose, it wouldn't exist. And loneliness, I think, really fits that description.
因为尽管我们最初的倾向是逃避孤独，去维持与那些我们并不喜欢其陪伴的人的联系，去维持那些无法满足我们的关系，以保持舒适，但孤独其实有一个非常棒的目的，因为它会促使你去主动联系他人。它会让你想要结交新朋友。我认为这是成长的一种决定性情绪。我也认为电影和影视作品靠这种观念牟利：
because although our first kind of inclination is to flee from loneliness, to stay connected with people whose company we don't enjoy, to stay in relationships with people who don't fulfill us, to stay comfortable, loneliness serves a really great purpose because it makes you want to reach out. It makes you want to make new friends. And it's a really defining emotion of growth, I think. I think also films and movies profit off this idea of,
孤独就像是一种疾病，是一场灾难，应该彻底避免，真的非常……非常擅长渲染这一点。比如我可以想到一些电影，比如《BJ单身日记》，那部电影真是糟糕透顶，但她孤独的核心在于她没有浪漫的伴侣。这是我在媒体中、特别是在电影和娱乐中经常看到的一种观念：如果你没有遇到一生所爱，如果你没有50个能和你一起去夜店、随时接听你电话的神奇朋友，你就应该感到孤独，你就应该为自己感到难过，你就应该觉得其他人都比你过得更有趣、拥有更好的朋友、拥有更多的朋友——而事实并非如此。关于这一点，我最不认同的一个部分就是这种观念：
loneliness is kind of like a disease it's a disaster it should be avoided really well um really really well and um like i can think of a couple like bridget jones's diary that movie is terrible terrible but the main crux of her loneliness is that she doesn't have a romantic partner that's something i see in media and like specifically like films and entertainment all the time this idea that if you haven't met the love of your life if you don't have like 50 amazing friends who are going to go clubbing with you and always answer your phone calls like you should feel lonely you should feel bad about yourself you should feel like everyone else is having more fun than you has better friends than you has more friends than you and it's not the case the one part about that i find the most issue with is this
如果你没有长期的恋爱关系，你就应该感到孤独。我真的很反感这种说法，因为我不认为情况是这样的。我也认为，在生活中拥有一个伴侣或拥有某种浪漫关系，并不会真正让你感觉好一点。如果非要说有什么影响的话，它只会让你更依赖对方来获得支持感和连接感，而在这种情况下，你本可以从巩固现有连接或创建新社群中获益更多。这真的只是一种权宜之计。就像那句名言说的：“你只有先爱自己，才能去爱别人。”而且，一个伴侣在减少那种孤独感和那种“缺乏陪伴”的感觉方面，能做的事情是有限的。
idea that if you don't have a romantic long-term relationship you should feel lonely and i really resent that because I don't think that that's the case and I also don't think that having a partner or having someone you know romantically in your life is really going to make you feel any better if anything it's just going to make you more dependent on them for a sense of support and a sense of connection when you may have benefited more from building on current connections or creating new community. It's really a band-aid fix. And it's that saying if like, you know, you can only love someone as much as you love yourself. And it's, you can only, you know, there's only so much that a partner can do for you in terms of kind of reducing that sense of loneliness and that
我认为恋爱关系只是一种快速的权宜之计。坦白说，这真的是一种权宜之计。当你处于孤立无援、得不到支持的境地时，很容易立刻扑向第一个向你展示温情、认可或关注的人。我经历过。我也做过。我不建议这么做，因为这唯一的用处就是把你从你本已拥有的朋友身边拉开，并让你更深地投入到那个人身上，也许是以一种不健康的方式。而当时对你更好的做法，可能是去直面这种情绪，接受它并建立社群，结交新朋友，走出去，而不是把自己封闭起来。这并不是说
feeling of not having someone. I think relationships are a quick fix. Quite honestly, they're such a quick fix. And it's so easy to be in a situation where you feel isolated and you don't feel supported and kind of jump to the first person who shows you affection or validation or attention. I've been there. I've done that. I don't recommend because the only thing it's going to do is draw you away from the people who you already have and it's going to make you more invested in that person, perhaps in an unhealthy way when it would probably have been better for you to sit with that emotion, come to terms with it and to have built community, to have made new friends to have put yourself out there rather than kind of closed yourself off. This is not to say that
你不能在孤独的同时拥有一段关系，或者如果你感到孤独而对的人出现了，你就应该逃避、绝对应该说“不”，因为你可能会变得相互依赖。我根本不是这个意思。我只是觉得有时候，恋爱关系在展现最好的自我时效果最好。如果你觉得你缺乏什么、缺失什么，并指望那个人来填补你，这并不总是长远的最优解。如果他们不在了呢？由于他们在满足你之前无法在别处得到的需求（至少暂时是这样），你对失去他们的恐惧感就会变得更强烈。我认为这相当危险。可能不推荐这样做，但我也确实理解那种想要紧紧抓住某人的需求。
you can't be lonely and have a relationship or if you're lonely and the right person comes along, like you should flee and you should absolutely say no because you could become codependent. That's not what I'm saying at all. I just think sometimes, you know, relationships work best when you are your best self. And if you feel like you're lacking something or missing something and that person is going to fill it for you. It's not always going to be the best long-term solution. What if they're not there? The fear of losing them will be stronger because they're satisfying a need that until that point you haven't been able to get elsewhere, or at least for a while. I think it's quite dangerous. Wouldn't probably recommend it, but also I do understand this need to like latch on to someone
我认为在二十多岁时，总会经历一段非常艰难的孤独期，因为普遍存在的规律、普遍的改变状态，以及当我们试图建立独立于父母、独立于家庭、独立于大学、独立于工作的生活时，我们所有人都会被推入的波动之中。我们试图向外拓展。
else. I think there are always going to be periods of really hard loneliness in our 20s because of just the universal nature, the universal kind of state of change and that there's fluctuations that all of us are kind of pushed into as we try and establish our own lives separate from our parents, separate from our families, separate from our universities, from our jobs. We try and branch out. and there isn't always going to be a place for you to slot right into, and sometimes it takes a little bit of effort. The other thing that really contributes to loneliness, I think, in our 20s, is that it's so natural and it's just a God-given truth that you're going to lose people.
而并不总是有一个现成的位置让你直接契合进去，有时这需要付出一点努力。我认为，在二十多岁时，另一个真正导致孤独的原因是：你会失去朋友，这是一个自然规律，也是一个不争的事实。你会失去朋友，与人失去联系，觉得（你知道的）与以前的朋友之间的连接在逐渐减弱。我认为在二十多岁时，这是一个尝试不同身份、尝试不同自我版本的绝佳十年，这些自我版本会出于不同的原因与不同的人产生连接。但随着你长大，随着你越来越清楚自己究竟是谁，那些你以前的朋友不再真正符合这个形象了。他们不再真正融入你的身份。失去朋友是完全正常的。
You're going to lose friends, lose touch with people, feel like, you know, a bit of a diminishing in connection with people that you have been friends with previously. I think in our 20s it's kind of the chance, it's a beautiful decade to get to try on different identities and to get to try on, you know, different versions of ourselves who connect with people for different reasons. But as you grow up and as you figure out more of who you actually are, those people who you were previously friends with no longer really fit that profile anymore. They no longer really fit into your identity. It's totally normal to lose friends. if you're not losing friends you're not growing as a person but it can sting it can really hurt
如果你没有失去朋友，说明你作为一个人没有在成长。但这确实会刺痛，确实会很痛，
because you loved them and they served a purpose in your life and also because they're just another form of social connection even if you're feeling that relationship decaying or you you know you don't have as much to talk about anymore you hang out with them and you don't always leave feeling amazing it's really hard to let go of those people because you don't want to be alone you don't want to, you don't want to, like, get to the end of the line and be like, oh, you know, I dumped all these people, like, all these people kind of fizzled out. And now I have no one. But here's the thing. There is no point staying in friendships or relationships that no longer serve you. All it's going to do is, it's not weigh you down because I don't think people
因为你爱过他们，他们在你的生活中发挥过作用，还因为他们是社交连接的另一种形式，即使你感觉到那种关系正在腐化，或者你（你知道的）不再有那么多共同语言，你和他们一起出去玩，离开时并不总是感觉好极了。要放手那些人真的很难，因为你不想孤身一人。你不想……你不想走到尽头时说：“哦，（你知道的）我甩了所有人，就像所有人都在慢慢疏远，然后我现在谁也没有了。”但事情是这样的：留在那些不再适合你的友谊或关系中是没有意义的。它所做的一切——并不是说他们会拖累你，因为我不认为人们会拖累你——而是占用空间，占用那些本可以更好地被其他人利用的、本来就已经很忙碌的生活。认清你和另一个人不再是同路人了，
weigh you down, but take up space and, or are already pretty busy lives that may have been better used by someone else. It's not a crime. It's not a sin to, recognize that you and someone else are not the same people anymore you don't fit into each other's lives as easily anymore and to just allow both of you to move on and to find people who do to give them the space to discover people who are better suited to them there's no point being bitter about it i think you know i've had this happen a lot of times and i'm sure you have as well or if you haven't you will like no one is going to grow and develop in exact parallel to you on the same kind of wavelength and the same timeline. There is going to be
你们不再那么容易融入彼此的生活，并允许彼此继续前行、去寻找真正合适的人，给他们空间去发现更适合他们的人，这并不是什么犯罪。对此感到怨恨是没有意义的。我想（你知道的）这种情况我已经经历过很多次了，我确信你也经历过，如果你还没有，将来也会遇到——没有人会在完全平行于你的轨道上、以相同的波长和相同的时间线成长和发展。
discrepancies between where someone else is at and where you're at. And maybe they're just in your life for a couple of months and they served a really amazing purpose. Maybe they're there for a few years. Maybe they're like your lifelong best part. But you can't keep every person you were friends with when you were like 18 at 30. It's just not possible because you need to be able to create new relationships and there's only so much time that you have in your day. I think a really good indicator of when it is time to maybe start not so much pulling away but start creating space for new people is when you feel lonely when you're around someone else. When the connection is now missing and I had this with a friend and I really love for them dearly for so long we were such
别人的处境和你的处境之间总会有差距。也许他们只是在你生命中出现几个月，却发挥了非常惊人的作用。也许他们陪伴了几年。也许他们就像你一辈子的死党。但你不可能在30岁时还留住18岁时交的所有朋友。这是不可能的，因为你需要能够建立新的关系，而你的一天时间是有限的。我认为，当你在某人身边时感到孤独，这真的是一个很好的指标，表明也许是时候开始——与其说是疏远，不如说是为新的人腾出空间了。当连接已经缺失时。我和一个朋友就有过这种经历，我真的很深爱她很久了，我们曾是那么
good buddies but that we were really good friends for that part of our lives. And during that time, we were going through the same stuff. We were doing the same things. We had the same schedule. And then when those things started to fall away, you realized that it's not that you don't have anything in common. And it's not that that's a bad thing. It's not that they were a bad person. Our lives just weren't in line anymore.
好的哥们儿，我们在生命的那个阶段是很好的朋友。在那段时间里，我们经历着同样的事情。我们做着同样的事情。我们有着相同的日程安排。然后当这些事情开始消失时，你意识到这并不是说你们没有什么共同点。这也不是一件坏事。并不是说他们是个坏人。只是我们的生活不再合拍了。
And it's okay to be like, that's, well, I'm just going to let you go and let you have the best life you can have even if I'm not in it. But there's still space there. And I think that's where that lonely feeling comes from. because they still occupied your mind. Even if you weren't having the best time, you still enjoyed their company. Like, you were still friends with them for a reason, but it's good not to hold on to that just because you're afraid of being alone.
说“好吧，我要放手让你去过你能过的最好的生活，即使我不在其中”是没有问题的。但那里仍然有空间。我认为孤独感就是从这里产生的。因为他们仍然占据着你的脑海。即使你当时过得并不是最好，你仍然享受他们的陪伴。就像，你和他们做朋友还是有原因的，但最好不要仅仅因为害怕孤独而抓着不放。
It's like almost like, I think I had this for a while where I would hoard people. I would like hoard them because almost like someone, you know, keeps like inanimate objects or just like random objects, arbitrary things. because they're always worried of like, oh, what if one day I might need this? And this is like something with hoarding. If you've ever watched that show about hoarders, where they're like, but what if one day I really need this incredibly specific tack, or like this really specific piece of blue tack,
这简直就像——我想我有一段时间也是这样，我会囤积人。我会像囤积物品一样囤积他们，就像有人（你知道的）收藏无生命的物体、或者只是随机的物品、随意的物件一样。因为他们总是担心：“哦，万一有一天我可能会需要这个呢？”这就像囤积狂身上的某种特质。如果你看过那个关于囤积狂的节目，他们会说：“但是万一有一天我真的需要这个极其特殊的图钉，或者像这个非常特殊的蓝丁胶，
or this really specific piece of kitchenware? And I can't let that go because then I'll be without. And I won't be prepared for whatever the situation deals me. The thing is, you will be. You absolutely will be. And it's the same with friendships. Sometimes you keep people around because you're worried about what it would mean if they weren't there. And you're worried about what if one day I turn around and I do really need them.
或者这个非常特殊的厨房用具呢？我不能放手，因为那样我就没有了。我就无法应对生活抛给我的任何情况。”事实是，你会的。你绝对会的。友谊也是如此。有时你把人留在身边，是因为你担心如果他们不在了会意味着什么。你担心万一有一天我回过头来，真的需要他们怎么办。
And that's where the fear of loneliness I think really starts to build and bubble. I guess I've been rambling for a while and if you found yourself on this episode, what did you expect? No, just kidding. It's just one of those days, you know. Just one of those feelings and I think it's important to share it and to, um, feel like other people understand this because I think that's what I would like and what I look for you know I don't know if you like this but what I'm feeling like a specific emotional feeling
我想，对孤独的恐惧就是从这里开始积聚和冒泡的。我想我刚才东拉西扯了好一阵子，如果你发现自己听了这一集，你还期望什么呢？不，开玩笑的。这只是那种日子，你知道的。只是那种感觉之一，我认为分享这种感觉很重要，并且（嗯）感觉其他人也理解这一点，因为我想这就是我想要的以及我寻找的（你知道的）——我不知道你是否喜欢这样，但每当我有一种特定的情感感受时，
I always like look up podcasts about that like using keywords because it's always comforting to know that others are feeling that way as well the thing about losing people and about growing and feeling lonely is that from pain and from hurt comes like the most amazing renaissance of growth and of just prosperity and I really believe that I think that that is the sole purpose of really hard times in our life is it makes us stronger and it creates a bedrock of kind of inner strength and inner reliability and perseverance and independence that is just invaluable later in your life that's invaluable at any point in your life and it really is and kind of blessing to get to go through periods of suffering,
我总是喜欢用关键词搜索关于那个主题的播客，因为知道其他人也有同感总是令人感到安慰。关于失去朋友、成长和感到孤独，奇妙的是，从痛苦和创伤中会孕育出最神奇的成长与繁荣的复兴，我真的深信不疑。我认为这就是我们生命中经历艰难时期的唯一目的，它使我们变得更强大，并建立起一种内在力量、内在可靠性、毅力和独立的基石，这在你的晚年是无价的。在你的生命中的任何时刻它都是无价的。这真的是一种祝福，能够经历受苦的时期，
knowing what comes out at the other end, knowing that you've really been forged in the fire. So from loneliness and pain, I guess, comes growth. That's what I'm trying to say. You know, from it also there's an appreciation of the people who are around you. I promise if you're feeling lonely, you're not alone, and I know that sounds so cliche, but sometimes I just sit back and I just like make a mental list
了解另一端会迎来什么，知道自己确实在烈火中被淬炼过。所以我想说的是，从孤独和痛苦中会孕育出成长。这就是我想表达的。你知道的，由此产生的是对身边人的感激。我向如果你感到孤独，你并不孤单，我知道这听起来太陈词滥调了，但有时我只是坐下来，在脑海中列一个清单，
of the people who I love and who I could call and who would be there for me and it's always so much longer than I think it's going to be. I'm always like, oh, I've really got like two friends and then you're like, no, I don't. Like these people, I appreciate them so much and it's the quality of the friendships, not the quantity that matters so much more to me now that is just so much more important. And maybe that's like the solution is just having absolute and just insatiable gratitude for what you do have in your life, for the people who you do have,
列出那些我爱的人、我可以打电话的人、会为我出现的人，这个名单总是比我想象的要长得多。我总是会想：“哦，我真的只有两个朋友。”然后你会发现：“不，我不是。这些人，我太感激他们了。”现在对我来说，更重要的是友谊的质量，而不是数量，这才是最重要的。也许解决办法就是对你生活中已经拥有的东西、对你确实拥有的人，
for the people who love you, for those rare people who have grown in the exact same, like in complete unison with you as a person. It's just like wonderful. And it is made so much more wonderful when you don't have the fluff, when you don't have all those extra items
对爱你的人、对那些与你作为一个人以完全同步的方式成长起来的罕见人，抱有绝对的、无法餍足的感激之情。这简直太美妙了。当你的生活中没有那些浮华，当你的周围没有那些多余的物品或多余的人时，这种美好就会成倍放大，你无法和那些人共度那么多高质量的时光。这只是一刻的痛苦，但也带有一刻的感激去认识到这一点。另一件真正能帮到我的事情是，知道生活中唯一承诺的事就是改变和时间的流逝。即使你现在感觉不是很好，难道这不正是时间最棒的地方吗？它总是在向前迈进。总会有改变的。
or extra people surrounding you or in your life who, you can't spend as much quality time with those people. Like it's just like a moment of pain, but also a moment of gratitude to recognize that as well. And the other thing that really kind of helps me is just knowing that the only thing in life that's promised is change and is the movement of time. And even if you're not feeling like amazing right now, isn't that just the best thing about time? It always moves forward. There's always going to be change.
你的生活总会有所改善。即使事情变糟了，这也意味着它们最终会变好。事情不会一直糟糕可怕下去。我经常想这个。我无时无刻不在想这个，尤其是在现在。而且，（你知道的）每当我答应去做一件我其实不想去的事情时，我都会这么想——这可能是你遇到一个全新、了不起的人的时刻，这个人能满足你所有的需求，简直不可思议，会成为你的新挚友。或者你只是遇到了一个能进行美妙对话的人，这会让你感觉更多的连接和更多的
There's always going to be improvement to your life. And even if things get bad, it means that eventually they will get better. Things do not stay terrible and awful for long. And I think about that a lot. I think about it all the time, especially right now. And, you know, I think about it every time I say yes to something that I kind of don't want to go to. Like, this could be the moment where, like, you meet, like, the new, amazing person who just fulfills all your needs and who's just, like, incredible and, you know, a new best friend. Or he just made somebody who had a great conversation with, and it makes you feel more connected and more.
被理解。TikTok上有个视频我有时喜欢看，上面说：你生命中还没有遇到所有你会爱的人。难道这不是有史以来最美妙的事情吗？你还没有遇到你生命中所有你会去爱、会为之投入、也会为你投入的人。如果你把时间花在（你知道的）顾影自怜上，你就不会遇到他们。是的，同情有其空间，悲伤有其空间，悲哀和痛苦有其空间。但归根结底，你不能在那种状态下呆太久。
more understood. There's this TikTok that I like to watch sometimes and it says you haven't yet met all the people in your life who you will love. Isn't that just the most beautiful thing ever? You haven't yet met all the people in your life who you will love and who you will invest in and who will invest in you. And you won't get to meet them if you spend, you know, time feeling sorry for yourself. Yes, there's space for pity, there's space for sadness, there's space for, for for grief and for pain. But at the end of the day, you can't really be in that state for too long.
你不能永远待在那里。那里不是你的家。你必须不断成长、不断前行，并知道转角处有棒极了的人会欢迎你、支持你、理解你。难道这不正是世界给予我们的最美妙的承诺吗？谢谢你收听这些。我正坐在湖边，
You can't stay there forever. It's not a home for you. You've got to keep growing and keep pushing and know that there are amazing people around the corner who will welcome you and support you and understand you. And isn't that just the most beautiful promise that the world gives us? Thanks for listening to that. I'm just sitting at this lake.
我坐在大自然中。我今天去进行了一场美丽的散步。这总是让我感觉更好，活动身体，走出去，走到户外。大自然的美妙之处就在于此。它不在乎你是谁。它不在乎你的感受。它对所有人都毫不留情，无论你的过去如何，无论你的未来如何，无论你此刻的感受如何，无论你伤害过谁，无论谁伤害过你。我认为它只是那个伟大的平衡器。所以这也许也是应对孤独的一个秘诀。走出去。
I'm sitting in nature. I went for this beautiful walk today. And it always makes me feel better, moving my body, getting out, getting outdoors. That's the beautiful thing about nature. It doesn't care who you are. It doesn't care what you're feeling. It's ruthless to everyone, regardless of your past, of your future, of how you're feeling in the moment, of those you've hurt, of those who've hurt you. It's just like the great equalizer, I think. So maybe that's also a tip for dealing with loneliness. Get outside.
对一切说“YES”，然后走到户外。这就是我的秘诀。其中一个秘诀是代表悉尼说的。爱你。谢谢她为这期节目做出的贡献（如果她在听的话）。但如果你也有这种感觉，我只想向你发送爱。你不是唯一的一个。我想这就是重点。当你意识到自己不是唯一一个感到孤独的人时，你会感到没那么孤独。我们有一个庞大的俱乐部。这只是一刻。
Say yes to everything and get outside. There's my tip. One of those is on behalf of Sydney. Love you. Thanks for contributing to this episode if she's listening. But if you're feeling this way, I just want to send you love. You're not the only one. I guess that's the thing. You can feel less lonely in the knowledge that you're not the only one feeling lonely. There's a whole club of us. And it's just a moment.
这只是一种感觉。一切总会好起来的。真的会。我记得在大三刚开始时感到如此刻骨铭心的孤独，
It's just a feeling. It always gets better. It really does. I remember feeling so keenly lonely at the start of my third year of uni. and saying to my boyfriend at the time, like, all I want is some new friends. I just need new friends. I'm so lonely. I feel so alone.
并对当时的男友说：“我想要的就是一些新朋友。我只是需要新朋友。我太孤独了。我觉得自己好孤单。”
And yeah, it took a couple months. It took like half a year. But then all of these amazing people started showing up. And you know who those people are now? Those are some of my closest friends. I'm going to see one of them as we speak right after I finish recording this. And I met her because she, like, asked for something that I put up on, like, Facebook marketplace.
是的，这花了几个月。花了大约半年时间。但随后所有这些了不起的人开始出现了。你知道现在那些人是谁吗？他们是我最亲密的朋友。我录完音后正准备去见其中一个人。我认识她是因为她（比如）在Facebook Marketplace上询问我发布的东西。
And we kind of knew each other, but not really. and I was like, I'll give it to you for free, just take me out for brunch. And we went out for brunch, and now she is one of my closest friends and just most loyal companions and strongest relationships I have. And I really hope it's like that for the rest of our lives. So everything does improve slowly. It might take time. But there are so many people out there, so many people out there who are going to appreciate
我们算是认识，但不太熟。我说：“我免费送给你，只要你带我去吃早午餐。”我们出去吃了早午餐，现在她是我最亲密的朋友之一，是我最忠实的同伴，也是我拥有的最强有力的关系之一。我真心希望余生都能如此。所以一切都在慢慢改善。可能需要时间。但外面有那么多的人，外面有那么多的人会欣赏
just everything about you. And even the things you might not like about yourself, they may love. and that's just such a good feeling to hold on to and to know that time moves on, things change. And you won't feel like this forever. Anyhow, kind of a sad episode, honestly, but also vulnerable, which is what I kind of like to bring to the podcast. I've talked about so many things like toxic relationships and unrequited love. This is just the next one on the list, I feel like. How could I not talk about loneliness at some point on this podcast?
关于你的一切。甚至连你可能不喜欢自己的地方，他们也可能会喜欢。能够抱着这种美好的感觉，知道时间在流逝，事情在改变，这真是一种很好的体验。你不会永远这样感觉的。总之，这真的是一期挺伤感的节目，但也足够脆弱，而这正是我喜欢带给这个播客的东西。我已经谈过很多诸如毒性关系和单相思之类的事情。我觉得这只是名单上的下一个话题。我怎么能不在这个播客的某个时候谈谈孤独呢？
But thank you for listening. Thank you so much. And if you feel inclined, please feel free to leave a review of the podcast on Apple Podcasts or Spotify, leave a five-star rating. Follow us on Instagram as well. It really helps the podcast grow. It helps these kinds of, I would say, intimate, vulnerable conversations, reach the ears of people who maybe need to hear it. And if you've listened this far, maybe share that on. If you've gotten anything from it, share the word.
但谢谢你们的收听。非常感谢。如果你愿意的话，请随时在苹果播客或Spotify上为本播客留下评价，留下五星好评。也在Instagram上关注我们。这真的对播客的成长很有帮助。它有助于这些（我想说是）亲密的、脆弱的对话，传达到那些可能需要听到它的人的耳朵里。如果你听了这么远，也许可以把这期节目分享出去。如果你从中获得了什么，请传播出去。
tell your friends and thank you again for listening love you guys lots have a beautiful week hey what's good y'all you're listening and learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host care games this space is about black men's experiences
告诉你的朋友们，再次感谢你们的收听，爱你们大家，祝大家拥有美好的一周。嘿，大家好，欢迎收听《学得艰难》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing how many men carry a suit or armor it signals to the world that you not to be played with and just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast,
进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。这向全世界发出信号，你是不好惹的，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客、
or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学得艰难》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、fitness、
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed.
和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》？在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都跟同一个惯犯骗子约会过后，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。
I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我会成为他的最后一个目标。他休想逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，就在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。